senator Bernie Sanders from Vermont he
asked if the NSA is spying on Congress
and basically they said yeah we are this
is the statement that they released
NSA's authorities to collect signals
intelligence data includes procedures
that protect the privacy of us persons
such protections are built into and cut
across the entire process members of
Congress have the same privacy
protections as all US persons NSA is
fully committed to transparency with
Congress yeah I mean even the way they
worded that it's all backwards logic and
confusing and they're not outright
saying that they're spying on Congress
but they obviously are considering
Congress has an approval rate of like
six percent or something I feel like
this is a little karmically wonderful
but this is really horrible isn't it
well it's great because these are the
types of things that Congress has let
happen yeah and they think oh it's not
going to happen to me exhib some sort of
imaginary government protection but
Congress is not they don't have any most
limb don't have any sort of security
clearance or anything that would prevent
this so I think this is a good thing I
think it's great that someone finally
inquired into it to find out if they're
spying on Congress rather than assuming
no and then maybe it'll make them
actually pay attention to things that
they sign and things they vote on so
that to me is like the real issue here
is that they sign off on all this stuff
and it's not it's Congress it's the
Senate it's everybody they sign up on
all this stuff and then they later find
out oh it's affecting me too so could
this be the thing that gets the NSA
stuff to critical mass because now that
it's about ma'am they might have to do
something about it right well we're
seeing a series of blue ribbon panels
and hearings and they're going to be so
many people the White House is hosting a
meeting with members of Congress NSA and
other people that are influenced by this
and it's going to just be a disaster i
think because we do need national
security we do need intelligence to
protect the homeland but of course
they've gone too far and now it's just
going to be everyone will be finding out
about it and i think that's a big threat
yeah so I've been completely against
this whole thing obviously and I pretty
much agree with Rand Paul on almost
everything he said about this but how do
we as regular people that's funny when
you say you agree with Rand Paul's gonna
laugh
but how do we how do we as regular
citizens get to sort of negotiate what
we can accept because we don't know
about all the threats and that's what
they use against us all the time well
you don't know what's going on so how is
how do we have a rational conversation
about it so I think that the first thing
to say would we decide if we care what
the threat level is and does that mean
that we lose more personal freedom just
because of some implied threat or some
imaginary threat so basically it's like
saying we don't whether the threat is
you know somebody's going to come
terrorize us right now or the threat is
domestic or whatever we have to decide
this is the level that we're going to
take and then you get involved with the
people that vote on these things like
Congress and everyone else but I think
the problem is is that citizens people
like us aren't normally proactive we
think this is happening to us either way
if you can't do anything about it and
maybe we can't because honestly there
was really no movement on this until now
you're as you were saying now they're
having the blue ribbon panels and
they're caring about it suddenly it
wasn't until members of the government
that were affected by this or
potentially embarrassed by this that
they did anything yeah what does it say
that we needed a socialist senator to
bring them up right from Vermont any
nitration he identifies his socialist as
any sort of he's an independent but I
think he's kind of a socialist like what
does that say because nobody from the
Republicans rate was gonna really do it
nobody from the Democrats we need a
socialist to protect us from the NSA I
can't believe it's been seven months
since Edward Snowden release the
documents and that no one and of course
early phone record is on Bagwell do you
think the 435 members of Congress
haven't concluded that they are also
subjected to that it's its government at
its worse that governments speak we just
saw in the statement from the NSA is a
joke and they really need to be held
accountable and I'm glad that President
Obama is finally stepping up he's of
course been aware of all this and and a
party to it and I think he owes us an
explanation he definitely does owe us an
explanation what I think is interesting
about this is for all we know they're
spying on Obama too I mean that's that's
even been written about are they spying
on Obama if he only has the same
protections as the rest of us and as
Congress by that very statement they can
so doesn't that make you wonder who's
really in charge if we have this secret
organization that they're authorizing to
spy on them well none of the people that
we think are in charger really
and then also what matters is what can
then happen with that information
because once we figure out who is really
in charge then we figure out how they
could potentially leak information to
use it against their own people how they
could use it against us I can use it
against individuals because just
collecting data is bad enough but if we
don't even know who these people are
that are interpreting it and then and
what are their legal limitations on
releasing that type of stuff then it
becomes an even larger problem and
nobody should have such an absolute
power that's why we have three branches
of government and there's not really
this is kind of its own whole monster
now that can check anything under the
name of just fear yeah and any time you
have anything created out of simply fear
think this agency needs to exist because
we need to be able to collect data on
people but the fact that no one
questions them usually is simply based
on fear the socialist Congress had to
ask as the other Congress people would
have been called and they're not
Patriots right it's all based on fear so
it's basically you know no one's
checking it just because everyone's just
too afraid she James clapper be fired
he's the head of the NSA who you know
testified to Congress that were not
wittingly as he was scratching his head
we're not wittingly spying on people
should he be fired I mean he lied to
Congress under oath right I don't know
it's it's a very touchy subject I guess
my big concern is with Edward Snowden
and of course that is a big debate so
what should watch we do what do you
think we should do I think he's a
traitor and I really should be brought
back to this country and there are other
ways to go about releasing data
information as a whistleblower that are
throughout that are legal in the
government not to jeopardize all of our
agents not to jeopardize our
relationships with other countries like
Brazil and Germany where turns out we're
bugging the the phones of the the
leaders they're our allies so I think
there was very inappropriately brought
back to this country and I think should
be held accountable so I know the
comment sections gonna be blowing up
about that right now so to me it's like
there was no he had no choice he had to
do with the way he did it because Italy
they would have never believed him he he
he needed to do something crazy to shake
the system if he would have done this
well that he might have just disappeared
or had a car accident or whatever to me
it's like he's taught he's released this
great thing so we have to treat him as
such the problem is it's like is he a
traitor or is he
perfect example the Patriot exactly the
problem is there really is no gray area
it's like the proper government channels
for him and saying hey I don't think
this is a good thing that we're doing
probably would have just jailed him
silenced him threatened him screw him
possibly killed him who knows how far
that gets cuz I don't know but you know
I like it you were a little more
cautious I when I went right to the car
accident yeah I mean I think that all
the time too and I think of that so it's
like look if he had just gone and said
look there's things going on that I
don't agree with and I think you should
be aware of but I can't tell you what
they specifically are then no one would
have believed it had been a tinfoil hat
coupe so it's like is this an ends
justifies the means type situation and
none of us would have known about any of
this so it's it's he either is a traitor
or Patriot there's no grass so final
question of this uh shouldn't
progressives and libertarians completely
be leading the charge on this and
somehow work together so somebody like
Rand Paul who's completely against this
and then all the progress the true
progressives out there so I guess
someone like Bernie Sanders is this like
a perfect other job why what what's the
deal what's the deal with that I know
the problem is these are people that
can't get it together these are people
that share opinions with statistically
at least through you know through
calling the majority of people in
America these are people that seem to
have you know forward-thinking ideas and
for some reason just can't get it
together ever yeah any thoughts on that
I just think as Americans we need to
live honest lives I have nothing to hide
I'm aftermath I'm sorry and I figured my
phones have already been bugged but I
think no seriously we really need to be
aware that they're protecting us from
another 911 and from who knows what else
is going on in the world and i think
that the NSA serves a purpose so
obviously cross the line and going too
far